[Music]
hello everyone
uh so if some of you have been wondering
all this while that
when will the kinematics chapter ever
end
so it is with this lecture uh because we
are going to start the last topic of the
kinematics chapter
and the name of this topic is
strain compatibility now
this topic is a source of a bit of
confusion among students i have seen
this happen with
many of your seniors now
it is for this reason that we are not
going to discuss
strain compatibility like it is
discussed in most of the textbooks
uh we are not going to present uh any
underlying theory behind it
rather we are going to discuss it in a
very practical way
like uh how i mean what is the
motivation if at all for
uh for studying this so uh
so let's get down to the to the business
of discussing strain compatibility and
we will uh discuss it in the context of
what we have been discussing earlier so
uh
let's go down to our pages
so this is our topic uh but we'll first
uh start with uh
with a little bit of a recap from one of
our earlier pages
so if we go back
yeah so in one of these earlier lectures
we had mentioned this very very
important set of relations
all the strain displacement relations
and these were basically
uh six relations connecting
the various components of the strain
tensor with the various
derivatives um of the other
displacements
so the situation was like this that if
you are supplied with the displacement
fields so you are given how
u varies with x y z how v varies with x
y z and how w
varies with x y z then you can just plug
in these
formulas use this strain displacement
relations directly
and find out the various values of
epsilon x x epsilon y y
uh epsilon x y sum z and so on and so
forth
so the similar thing was written in in
the previous page also here
so here we had written all these things
so if you are given
u v w in as functions of x y z you can
just
directly obtain these epsilon x x y web
sunset
all that is fine the question that we
want to answer today
is uh let's go back to today's
page so the question we want to answer
today
is uh what
if we are faced with the reverse problem
so
what if we are
given the strain field
that is we are given the various
components of
epsilon i j
and we are asked
to find
the displacement components
so the situation is completely reversed
now
so earlier you had three variables which
were known to you u v
and w and from that you could find out
the six components of strain
but now it is the reverse thing meaning
that you know the six independent
components of string
so epsilon x x epsilon y y epsilon z z
epsilon x y
and y z epsilon zx all those are known
to you and from that you have to
reverse engineer or uh you need to find
out the
u v and w so uh
the situation is like this so because we
are facing the reverse situation
you think of it like this that you have
these
uh these relations
so i'm writing the strain displacement
relations just by reversing the left
hand side and the right hand side
so earlier we had written epsilon x x as
del u del x
now we are just writing the reverse
thing just to change our our orientation
so del u del x is equal to epsilon x
x del v del y is equal to
epsilon y y del
w del z is equal to
epsilon z
of del u del y
plus del v del x
that is equal to epsilon x y
of del v
del z
plus del w del y
that is equal to epsilon y z
and finally half del
w del x plus del u
del z that is equal to
epsilon zx
okay so we have these six equations and
you may think that fine we have six
equations we can just go forward and
solve this
uh we'll be able to find it out but
there is a little bit of a problem you
see
you can think of these six relations
that we have just written down
in reverse as six partial differential
equations
of course there are partial derivatives
here so they are partial differential
equations
so we have six partial differential
equations in hand and the things
that you need to solve for are what u v
and w so what so you have six
uh equations in hand but you only need
to solve
for three variables so it is like an
overposed problem
and that is where the problem is okay so
i repeat
what the problem is if you are given
epsilon x x epsilon so you put all those
things the the various components of
strain on the right hand side
and these six plane displacement
relations
you view them as six partial
differential equations
but partial differential equations to
solve what to solve
the three components not the six the
three components of the displacement
variable zone
u v and w so more number of equations
you have
than the number of variables and that is
where the problem is
so surely there must be something going
on in order to maintain the overall
consistency
and the the thing that we have to ensure
in order to to ensure to make sure that
the things
are indeed uh okay that is what is
referred to as the strain compatibility
okay so forget about the the whatever
the intricate maths might be involved
but practically this is what is the
situation so we have more number of
equations than
than the number of variables we have to
solve for okay
so uh so so if since we are discussing
the practical aspects of it
uh let us discuss a little example uh so
all these things they are uh they refer
to
a the the three dimensional system so as
a practical example we can take a
simplified
uh two dimensional version of the same
story
and we can illustrate actually that
there may actually arise a case
where this if you if you're if you're
given
any arbitrary sort of values of the
strains
it may not lead to a uh
to a proper set of solutions for the
displacement variable
okay so i'll i'll illustrate to you
and a so-called incompatible strain
field
okay so
[Music]
so illustration
of an incompatible
strain field so i'm telling you that
this is going to be incompatible
okay it's like telling you the the
result of a detective story
uh before telling you the story uh but
anyway
uh so let's say we have
epsilon x x is equal to
y square epsilon
x y is equal to 0
and epsilon y y is equal to 0
this is what is given to us let's write
this
it is given to us this given
and question is that
you find u v and w
okay so what can we do
well at the very outset
we can start with this epsilon x x equal
to y square
so because we are interested in finding
out the u v w
you just check from these reverse strain
displacement relations that this
del u del x is equal to epsilon x x that
is perhaps where you need to
uh that is what is uh perhaps you need
to use first of all
to perhaps obtain some
uh some expression for u
okay so we are we're going to do that in
the
in the next page
so what we have is del u
del x is equal to epsilon
x x is equal to y square
now this is a partial differential
equation uh
and we can we can solve this
[Music]
so what do we need to write here so had
this been a simple
or an ordinary differential equation
then you could have just put
a constant of integration here but this
is mind you
a partial derivative with respect to x
so the only thing that we could perhaps
write here
is that this will be some unknown
function of y so this f of
y this is a pure function of y this
f does not have any dependence on
x right now we do not know the form of f
so we'll investigate this
now uh we have some some form of
u now uh
what we can do is uh
we can uh we can try to
uh use the rest of the information
that is given to us so you know
you go back here and you note the
epsilon
x y is equal to zero
you also note that epsilon y y is equal
to zero
so
del v del y
that is equal to epsilon yy and that is
given as 0
so just like before what we can do is we
can find out
v as some function of
x all right
so from this expression of u and this
expression of v
involving the unknown pure functions of
y and the
and the pure function of x we can
find this epsilon x y is equal to
half del u del y
plus del v del
x and if we do this
if we actually substitute these
expressions of u
and v here what we will obtain is
half of so
the del u del y from here it will give
us twice
x y plus
d f d y please note
very carefully that i am not writing a
partial derivative here
this is an ordinary derivative because f
is a pure function of y
okay for the del v del x we just need to
write down
del g sorry d dg
this is d g d x not del g d x
not del g del x this is d g d x again an
ordinary derivative
okay so now we can compare the given
information what is given to us epsilon
x y is given
to us as 0 so
but epsilon x y
is given to be 0.
therefore we must have
half twice xy
plus df dy
plus dg dx
is equal to 0
or you can just remove this half here so
what we have
is twice xy plus
df dy plus
dg dx is equal to zero
this is where things get critically
important to look carefully
you see
this is some sort of an equation with
the right hand side as 0
you also note that f is a pure function
of y
which means that d f d y
is at best a function of y
g is a pure function of x so dj dx is at
best a pure function of x
it could be a constant this could be a
constant but
no matter what you do it will not
it cannot happen that just because you
do a derivative with respect to y
somehow
magically some kind of x dependence will
emerge here
similarly no matter what you do here
after the derivative of after you have
taken the derivative with respect to x
it simply cannot happen that a
dependence on y
will magically emerge here so this thing
will
still depend on why this thing will
still depend
only on x at best what can happen is
that this thing will turn out to be a
constant
this thing will turn out to be a
constant other than that nothing else
can happen
however this thing is sitting this is
the problematic part
the twice x y okay
so no matter what happens here and no
matter what happens here
this overall equation you please note
very carefully that this overall
equation
can never be satisfied you see suppose
this were a pure function of y
and this very pure function of x okay
then certainly this equation cannot be
satisfied
all right furthermore
suppose this were a constant suppose f
is uh suppose f
is like some k y
and suppose this g is like some cx
so after the first derivative with
respect to y this will give you just a
simple constant k
and this will give you a simple constant
c and then
suppose if this twice x y was not
present
then you could have obtained as a nice
equation that k
plus c is equal to zero that could have
been satisfied
but no matter what you do here this
twice x y
is always remaining there so this
equation
this this equation
can never be satisfied
and the problem
is with the twice
x y part
okay the problem is with the wise xy
part
now you just imagine for a second okay
just imagine for a second
that the twice x y part was not
not there it just hypothetically you
imagine that if
twice x y where absent
then the equation you have in your hand
is
d f d y plus
d g d x is equal to
zero
[Music]
now this thing that we have here
that uh that one of the terms is that
best a pure function of
y and the other one is a pure function
of x this is somewhat reminiscent of
what you
i believe what you may have come across
in your fluid mechanics course
uh so where you had
uh an equation like uh
like the gradient of the pressure the
dp dx on on the one hand in one of the
terms and on the other hand you had in
another term
the mu d square v
v x d y square so one of them
the term involving the v x was a pure
function of y
and the pressure was a pure function of
x and the way you proceeded from
in that equation so i believe this was
covered in the topic
uh some exact solutions uh
you you proceeded with the argument that
since one of them is a pure function of
y and other is a pure function of
x and and and on the right hand side is
equal to zero
so the only way this can be possible is
if and similarly here
that df dy is equal to
minus dg dx
is equal to some constant k
the only way this is possible is like
this but
you see this is this is true only if the
two x y were not there but here two x y
is very much present here
because this basically follows from the
strain field that was given to us
so because we have arrived at a
situation
where uh the strain field given to us
and the information that we are deducing
from
the obtained displacement field forms
from
u and from v whatever form of epsilon x
y we are obtaining
there is a mismatch okay that is why we
are saying that this is an
incompatible strain field i repeat
this is given to us rather arbitrarily
but it turns out that if we use epsilon
x x and epsilon yy
then the forms of u and v
we end up with it gives rise
to a form of epsilon x y like this
which is simply cannot be equal to this
particular form
and that is why this is an incompatible
strain field so
uh so with that uh
i believe i have covered whatever i i
wanted to cover
in this topic and as promised
with this we end the kinematics chapter
now the next chapter will be uh we'll be
dealing with
uh press and it is there
that will be concerned unlike the
kinematics chapter
with the loadings the forces and
everything
that actually brings about the
displacements and
gives rise to various sorts of strains
and in chapter next to that we'll be
discussing the connections
between stress stresses and strains so
all right
thank you very much